warning to Skipton a nun spoiler part of
this video click this button or skip to
the timestamp shown you have been warned
we open on our main man Subaru he's
named after a car so he probably hates
his life but apart from that he's just a
nerd outside on a full-on tracky suit
fortunately this is Japan so no one
thinks he's a [ __ ] chav he's on his
way home before literally blinking his
way into another world he kept up with
the winter anime season go so
immediately he's just like [ __ ] yeah I
mean bloody Kona suber after testing out
some non-existent powers and making some
meta commentary he then gets mugged by
pirates a kpop star and a mushroom but
not before a little [ __ ] runs past the
witness everything that's going on stops
says I'm kind of in a rush and [ __ ] off
cheeky [ __ ] the mugging continues but
then they're stopped by Good Smile
company's newest figurine range along
with the fluffy mascot enter emilia
sensing her 2d heroine status Honda
Civic immediately declares her best go
and instant waifu material she saves him
they start talking they save another
mushroom and then she explains that the
cheeky [ __ ] who ran off earlier stole
her insignia
so he's like if I help get you that
insignia back will I be able to tap that
ass and she's like [ __ ] no and he's
like more to bad doing anyway they
eventually find a place which turns out
to be an awful idea because they both
just get shanked to the back and he ends
up exactly where was at the beginning of
the day thus far the fact that he
immediately figured out that he got
transported to an alternate world he
obviously didn't watch you raced cuz
he's left standing there in the middle
of the street looking like a [ __ ]
thinking am i tripping balls so his
first instinct is to run to the place we
died where he finds Dwayne the rock
Johnson's granddad and the cheeky [ __ ]
still wanting to get the insignia back
he's just like look I'll sell you this
flip phone trust me it's worth four [ __ ]
ton of money all the cool kids are using
it nowadays just gas goodell before
anyone's convinced the chick that kills
him comes in we know it's her since she
has his crazy sexy kind of look like
she'd suck your dick and then bite it
off afterwards oh that's a face has
bitten off many dicks after some failed
negotiations and a casual slaughter he
wakes up again and he's still like why
the [ __ ] don't people die when they are
killed it takes another stabbed in the
back by kpop before has a [ __ ] lujah
he finally figures out the deal after
his millionth respawn realizing at this
point that his KD is worse than GT
former sir MSI yeah actually tries to
plan out his next move
in the process he runs into some bloke
called Reinhardt whose character design
screams I'm some kind of badass and also
I'm really hot but is that really worth
your dick Elsa
cuz it's those dick biting mouths again
she wonders why he's so scared of her
because she can smell the fear in him
and he's just like that's not fair mate
that's just piss before she can bite any
more dicks he runs off and we get the
same stand-up we always do except this
time Emilia and Kitty are here to help
Kitty is apparently quite powerful and
puts up a good fight but unfortunately
we find out she's too much of a lazy
[ __ ] to finish the battle and has a
bloody now things are looking pretty
grim before Reinhardt joins the battle
as predicted he's some kind of bigwig
Knight so everyone eggs him on to see
some of his swordplay
so he's like low okay and fires off a
tactical nuke toyota yaris think it's
[ __ ] ecstatic cuz he's finally got
past the tutorial boss only to find out
he has about 1 hp left after this we'll
get used to a bunch more characters in
Amelia's house including two maids a
child predator and a book wanker nothing
really much happens from here everyone
sassy we find out Amelia's eligible for
the throne he gets along with the blue
maid he tells the red made about the
story of the red and blue ogre she
remarks that she's never seen red versus
blue and everything's all hunky-dory
except for one night oh god he's [ __ ]
stumbling around again and throwing up
he's obviously had one too many pints
cuz he's fallen down again and got way
popped his arm realizing that someone's
killing him off at the end of the week
he tries setting up a trap and finally
it's revealed that it was blue made all
along so this is white Fox's newest
addition to their backlog of time-travel
shows of you know steins gate but it's
definitely one of the show to look out
for this season from a pretty good
bloody season if you ask me it revolves
around a main protagonists are Subaru as
he tries to survive this new fantasy
what he's literally blinked his way into
one day as he was doing the groceries
while he's seemingly just a normal kid
with no skills or powered compared to
everyone else in this world
the main gimmick used by the show's the
whole time loop thing where he
essentially resets to a point in time
every time he dies and well call me a
sucker for really enjoying plots we have
time loops in them but that's what sold
me on the show straightaway the way he
uses the time we've learned everything
that will happen and plan his actions
accordingly
I mean sure time loops are nothing new
at all with shows like steins gate
Higurashi and outside animate edge of
tomorrow and of course Groundhog Day
being the de facto standard but it
certainly hasn't been enough of a
prominent gimmick that I would call it
saturated either especially in the anime
medium what differentiates it from the
usual time loop concepts I've seen apart
from the fire is set in a fancy setting
is that the way that the loops are
structured seem to be more like he's
stuck in a world with video game
mechanics yes I know the whole guys
[ __ ] video game concept has been done
to death by now but I was actually
talking about how instead of having a
fixed time loop that he's constantly
trapped in the whole thing is structured
more like a respawn point with
checkpoints along the way like watching
one Rita trying to stumble his way
through dark souls for the first time
what what he's never done that before
what the [ __ ] there always seems to be a
certain event that he has to complete
before advancing through to the next
checkpoint
whether it be defeating a boss or just
surviving the week though what actually
constitutes as a checkpoint and how I
can stray from the path he's taken still
remains to be seen at this point in time
I also realized that viewing the show
kind of said something to me as a gamer
since watching him triggered this OCD
part myself that we just want to kill
myself and respawn if I couldn't get the
optimal path to completing an objective
though you know I can kind of understand
not wanting to get your guts sliced open
every time there's not too much to say
about the cast right now it's still
early on but at the moment Subaru kinda
reminds me of a younger
okabe rintarou with his eccentric and
all-around bright personality his
extensive knowledge of video games and
anime means he can mostly understand the
quirks and rules of the world he's
transported into you often providing
some meta commentary along the way which
a series uses to satire the whole
fantasy genre he's in pretty much the
rest of the female cast right now are
your typical flavours of sweet and cute
that always play some small kind of
syndra traits which I don't really have
an issue with cuz you know if you
haven't heard already I [ __ ] like
summaries
but before I do tell you guys who
hastened race because I know you're
[ __ ] out there rest assured that it's
not the overbearing karna Cinderella
girls and maniacal [ __ ] for no
apparent reason other than well they're
[ __ ] sundries it's the much tamer
kind where everyone is just super sassy
to the main character without being
outright mean my main criticism so far
is that I don't really know where the
show is going the first three episodes
set up the concept well Subaru had an
active goal he is working towards that
we can all get behind that also
established the rules of the world but
beyond that nothing much has really
happened there's no real purpose for why
is there what he's meant to be doing
besides just survive and it's missing
the same drive it had in the first few
episodes also if I were to get a bit
nitpicky as the character Subaru really
does handle the situation he's thrown
into a bit who well he immediately just
accepts that he was randomly transported
into another world
leaving behind whatever life he had
without ever dwelling on it or even
wondering why it happened
I mean no matter how much us plebs
fantasize about it we would at least be
a little bit shocked if we were
transported into a parallel world but
nope he's just like okay I guess I'll
just transport him to a parallel [ __ ]
world also considering some of the
brutal and gruesome way he's being
killed not to mention the mental strain
of resetting all emotional bonds you
constantly make he kind of just shrugs
it off week after week and I think
there's plenty of room for development
there but hopefully this will become
clearer as a series develops as I've had
a lot of fun with it so far or you know
could just let me down as the curse of
watching season 2 anime where you don't
how it's going to end so you know at
this moment I would definitely recommend
it as one of the anime to be watching
this season currently Reiser is
available on crunchyroll so you can go
to crunch Roy accomplished Amazon for
free month of premium membership and
yeah I think that's it so if you can
take any one thing from this video be
sure to remember this I [ __ ] like
cinders
hey guys is king IKEA I hope you enjoyed
this new format and trying out if you
have any comments or suggestions and
please leave it in the comment section
below
since I'm experimenting a lot with my
contents right now and if you're new
here be sure to check out my other stuff
also if you go to a so next week I'll be
posting a video with meetup details soon
so keep an eye out for that
but until then I've been giga that was
yeah my zone and I'll see you all next
time